PERFORMANCE AGAINST THE JET, 37.
MILLER, AFTER IT
PICKED UP BY CONOR GARLAND.
PULLED DOWN!
THERE WILL BE A PASS, FINDING
HÖGLANDER, BACK A SERIES OF SAVS
THEN HE ISAVE BUT NO REBOUND FOR
OF STOPPED BY DEMKO AND IT IS GR
DeBRINCAT, BROKEN UP AICE PASS A
PENALTY THERE.D
ESTIMATING THERE ASSISTS OVER
THAT TIME.
IT
HELPING HIM.
>> John S.: HE WAS BATTLING FOR
A HOOKING PENALTY AND
HAMONIC, TAKING THAT PASS.
WORKING HIS WAY DOWN THE AND SHS
AUNT.
>> John S.: THE FIRST SIGHTINGED
IN ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
PODKOLZIN,
KANE NOW AT C DID IN
THEIR
>> John G.: AND FOR JAKE
THEY BREAK IT UP AND NOW A LITTN
THAT ONE
♪  (music)
EKMAN-LARSSON, OFF OF THE POST
AND THAT'S
BURROUGHS, PETTERSSON TO GETS A.
CARPENTER, THE LOOSE PUCK.
THE CANUCKS WILL NOT LET
BACK TO GARLAND.
CENTRES, WHAT A SST PART OF THIS
GOING WIDE WITH HAGEL, REACHING.
>> John S.: 69.3.
>> John G.G. IN THE
DRAFT AND HIS TEAM NOW THE
ICING CALL.
AS PETTERSSON
INFIVE BY OUR COUNT AND MINUTEST
IN THE THIRD PERIOD, THE CNALTY,
HOOKING.
>> J J WITH
SPEED ANDCAN VOTE FOR YOUR
QUARTERBACKED BY QUINN HUGHES.
WITH DEMKO NOW OUT TOT
AFTER IT, THIRD PERIOD.
>> John G.: AND THAT ONE WENEN
-D
IT IS de HAAN WHO
FLEURY, FIGHTS IT OFF.
AND de HAAN, ELIAS PETTERSSON
NOW KEEPING THAT
OF THE GLASS, OUT OF PLAY.
NO PENALTY, JUST A WHISTLE WITH
17 SECONDS LEFT